well hey there we're going to talk about
everything Google memo related we're
going to talk about the fact that
they're a bunch of people who think the
colin kaepernick must must must be hired
back into the NFL plus the greatest ad
you will ever see for gay rights from
the Royal Dutch Airlines a lot of stuff
going on I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
oh we have many things to get to today
and I will be discussing all the things
that have to do with this Google memo
the one through in depth yesterday here
on the program I will be spitting hot
fire like one of Danny's dragons on Game
of Thrones
incinerating entire lines of enemy
troops but before we do any of that
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Boland branch so as you
know these I've said it a thousand times
at this point I suck at sleeping I'm
really bad at it that means when I get
into my bed at night it must be
comfortable it must be wonderful it must
be the greatest bed that ever was and
that means the sheets have to be really
good so people tend to think about all
the other aspects of sleeping but you
never think about your sheets you just
go over to the local department store
and you pick up the one that has the
highest thread count because you don't
know what that means and then you put it
on your bed and it turns out you're
sleeping on a plastic tarp well that's
why you need to go over to bowl and
branch calm their sheets are so good
today are all I will buy now for me for
my children they're incredibly
incredibly comfortable they are they
breathe they do not feel heavy on you
that they're just they're terrific
sheets bolt and branch calm there's a
reason that 3x president and Bill
Clinton's lovers apparently use bullet
and branch sheets you can check them out
over at bull and branch comm bull and
branch comm and right now they sell for
about half the price of normal expensive
retail sheets with the markup there's no
markup with bull and branch you will
love them and you can try them free for
well you can try them for 30 days and
see for yourself and if you don't like
them then you can return them for a full
refund
so essentially get to try them for free
go to bull and branch comm today you'll
get $50 off your first set of sheets
Plus free shipping when you use that
promo code bed you buy the sheets you
bring home try them three days see if
you like them I promise you're going to
love them there's no way you're going to
want to return them your buy extra set
it's $50 off plus free shipping right
now at bull and branch calm Bo LL and
branch calm promo code Bennigan's that
promo code Ben get that $50 off your
first set of sheets right now and again
use promo code Ben also so that they
know that we sent you and they continue
to advertise with the number one
podcasts in news and media oh yeah
bull and branch com promo code bed by
the way we still are number two overall
on iTunes right now so please go
subscribe if you have not and leave us a
review we appreciate it that's what
helps send our ratings of sky rocketing
we are now number two overall behind
Oprah come on guys we can't lose to
brah I mean I know she's going to give
you a car and you a car and you a car
we're not going to give you a car but we
will give you the satisfaction of having
defeated Oprah if we eventually take
over the number one slot so go ahead and
check that out okay so run to the the
situation over at Google so last night
Google decided that they had to fire
their employee the evil evil employee
who suggested in a memo that Google was
leftist and closed-minded which is weird
since if you don't want to prove that
you're leftist and closed-minded perhaps
you shouldn't fire the guy who says
you're leftist and closed-minded that's
kind of a bad move but they fired him
the Google Revolutionary Brigade has
asked that employee his name's James at
d'amour and the Google CEO sundar Pichai
stated that the the 10 page memo had
quote violated the line by advancing
harmful gender stereotypes in our
workplace to suggest a group of our
colleagues have traits that make them
less biologically suited to that work is
offensive and not okay I love when the
left use of the phrase not okay because
they really mean by that is we should
take you out at sunrise to the stake and
light you on fire not okay is is if
they're if they're under stative way of
saying you're not see and we should beat
the crap out of you but here is the
problem just as with the rest of the
media nobody read the memo nobody read
the memo nothing in the memo says that
women as a group are less biologically
suited to being in tech there's nothing
in the memo that says that okay so the
media obviously didn't read the memo and
so now they are simply attempting to
make up what they wish the memo said
because it's easier to make a case that
the guy should be fired if you make up
what he said so here are some of the
things that it didn't say so far let me
start with this here's what the memo
actually here's what the memo said it
made three main contentions first it
said that Google had a leftist bias
which prevented them from hearing other
viewpoints obviously true because you
just fired the guy who said you had a
leftist bias second it said that part
not all a part of the discrepancy in
employment between men and women at
Google was attributable not to sexism
but to large-scale group differences
between men and women again this makes
perfect sense and is obviously true in
the same way that it is true that the
wage gap is largely explained in the
United States by different choice of
jobs different amount of time that women
want to spend in the workplace as that's
to say that an individual woman can't
outperform a man is that say that an
individual woman can't perform
the same job a man can do depending on
the job it is to say that group
differences do make a difference when
you are looking at aggregate when you're
looking at the aggregate and finally the
memo said Google should actually try to
make employment easier for women in
general through a series of non illegal
means in other words not through hiring
quotas and diversity quotas but through
making it more attractive for women to
be at Google does any of that sound
radical to you if so you're more on
I mean you personally I don't mean on
average I mean if you actually think
that's a horrible thing that's in this
memo then you are a stupid person but
the media are just lying about what this
memo actually said so first of all
they're lying about people like me who I
think the memo is fine and that Google
is ridiculous for having fired the guy
so Newsweek ran a piece today saying the
alt-right kicks back against Google the
alt-right
do they even know who I am I was the
number one target of the alt-right
according to the anti-defamation league
last year in Newsweek said I was alright
it was the medium there there's another
there there's several other publications
that suggested that I was alright okay I
understand the left's desperate attempt
to paint every one on the right assault
right but it's just nonsense but in
terms of the memo itself the memo itself
does not say all the things that you're
hearing in the media so today on CNN CNN
ran a segment claiming that James
d'amours memo stated that women are
quote unquote biologically unfit for
tech there's nothing in the memo that
remotely says that in fact a more says
the opposite the media can't comprehend
a basic basic truth okay when I say a
group on average is different from
another group on average that does not
mean that individuals in that group can
be outstanding okay and it does not mean
that they can't be outstanding
individuals in the group can be
outstanding right the fact is if I say
seven-year-old as an average are not as
smart as fifteen year olds that doesn't
mean that every seven-year-old is not as
smart as a fifteen year old it means on
average they're dumber than fifteen year
olds they're maybe a seven year old
who's a genius and is the smartest and
fifteen year old that doesn't mean then
seven year olds and fifteen year olds
have the same average level of
intelligence okay but the media because
they're morons collectively right I'm
saying on average the media are morons
not individually every one of them is a
but collectively they're morons
okay when they say that when they say
that the guy is arguing that women are
unfit for tech what he's actually saying
is women on average are different from
men not that this particular woman is
different from this particular man
okay here's what two more rows now I'm
not saying not saying I love how this
works he says here's what I'm not saying
the media says you're saying it and
Google says you're fired he says I'm not
saying that all men different from all
women in the following ways or that
these differences are just I'm simply
stating that the distribution of
preferences and abilities of men and
women differ in part due to biological
causes and that these differences may
explain why we don't see equal
representation of women in tech and
leadership many of these differences are
small and there's significant overlap
between men and women so you can't say
anything about an individual given these
population level distributions right
okay so but according to what this means
the what he's saying is that every woman
is worse than every man intact
that's clearly not what he is saying the
reason that it is important to look at
averages is because when you're looking
at statistical averages with regard to
wages when you're aggregating data you
have to look at all of the relevant
confounding factors okay you'd be a bad
social scientist if you failed to do
this he reiterates this point later in
the memo he says I'm not saying that we
should restrict people to certain gender
roles I'm advocating for quite the
opposite
treat people as individuals not as just
another member of their group so what
he's saying is Google you say that we
need to hire more women and what I'm
saying to you is why don't we just hire
more qualified people right why don't
you base it on their individual
qualifications why does it have to be we
need to hire more women you cannot
simultaneously if your Google hold these
two dots at the same time it is deeply
important that we hire lots of women
because women make the workplace more
diverse and women are identical to men
in all relevant respects you can't hold
those two things simultaneously it
doesn't work that's what the Moore is
saying just to prove this he even
includes this particular chart in the
memo itself okay here this is the chart
okay it says populations have
significant overlap and then it shows a
trait and it shows two bell curves right
a purple bell curve and green bell curve
and it shows the purple bell curve and
the green bell curve they share some
space but the the purple bell curve is
shifted a little bit to the left on
whatever this x-axis is okay and then he
says reducing people to their group
identity and assuming the average is
representative ignores its overlap this
is dad and I don't endorse that he's
explicitly saying what they're saying
that he's not saying right he's
explicitly saying you can't judge
individuals by group differences but
group differences do make a difference
when you're
analyzing the data which of course is
true right this chart is basically
showing what I told you yesterday for
those missed it what I said yesterday is
that what this chart shows is that women
on average probably score very similarly
to men with regard to tech but when it
comes to the out layers when it comes to
you know the the ends of the spectrum
there's a thicker end for men meaning
that there are more men who are in the
upper echelon than women who are in the
upper echelon even if the averages are
very similar ok so that's the first
thing the media is telling you about
this memo that is not true that he is
saying that all women are unqualified
protect absolute crap doesn't say that
anywhere in the memo and all that's
happening here is that the media are
animated they've come up with a
preconceived notion which is a disguised
sexist and now they're going to work to
turn him into a sexist ok second thing
they say that this guy said two more
said in the Google memo that he didn't
say diversity is bad ok two more says
literally the first words of the memo I
value diversity and inclusion in fact he
offers an entire section of his memo
devoted to quote non-discriminatory ways
to reduce the gender gap he suggests
that Google makes software engineering
more people oriented with pair
programming and more collaboration
because women enjoy motional connection
more than men allow those exhibiting
cooperative behavior to thrive make tech
and leadership less stressful and
allowing and truly endorsing as part of
our culture part-time work right all of
this would definitely make Google more
attractive place for women to work ok
one of the things about about women in
the workplace is that women tend to want
to work part time more than men because
when they have kids they want to spend
more time at home with the kids give us
this true of my wife it's true of women
on average Mayda more says he believes
that arbitrary social engineering of
tech just to make it appealing to equal
portions of both men and women would be
foolish but if there's a goal of helping
the company succeed and having more
women would help us do that
then we should definitely try and create
a culture where this thrives that sounds
like someone who wants fewer women in
the workplace or does it sound like
someone who just wants to get rid of
quotas based on sex this guy just wants
to get rid of quotas based on sex but he
suggests ways that you can make the
workplace more attractive women hey the
other thing the media says that this guy
says that he doesn't say ok and they're
lying about it they say that d'amore
said that sexism doesn't exist does it
direct quote from the memo quote I am
not denying that sexism exists quote I
hope it's clear that I'm not saying that
diversity is bad that Google or
societies
100% fair that we shouldn't try to
correct for existing biases or that
minorities have the same experience of
those in the majority our larger point
is that we have an intolerance for ideas
and evidence that don't fit a certain
ideology and final lie that the media
have been telling about this memo and
it's being told by people on the Left
also is that the memo promotes violence
the memo is in some way making people
feel uncomfortable it's first of all as
I mentioned yesterday when we talked
about the response of the diversity and
inclusion officer at Google when she
says some troops are uncomfortable it's
funny this guy's truths make people
uncomfortable but that's bad we have to
fire him but if you make him
uncomfortable
that's fine and he just has to go along
with the program here's what he actually
write he says quote the same compassion
for those tina's weak creates political
correctness which constrains discourse
and is complacent to the extremely
sensitive PC authoritarians that use
violence and shaming to advance their
cause while Google hasn't harbored the
violent leftist protests that we're
seeing universities the frequent shaming
in TGIF and in our culture has created
the same silent psychologically unsafe
environment so he's making the case
against violence he's saying if you keep
attributing motives to people without
any sort of rationale then they're going
to you're going to want to get violent
with them more often he's basically
saying what's happening in college
campuses could come to Google and it has
come to Google now there are a bunch of
funny things about this particular story
that are true link rel first of all he
is saying that he probably will file
some sort of lawsuit against Google on
the basis that they terminated him
wrongly now it's an at-will state
California's an at-will state I believe
in that little employment I don't think
employers should have to hire him the
Atome is a right to be employed by
Google but what he is saying is that he
was actually whistleblowing on illegal
activity happening inside Google
discriminatory activity happening inside
Google and they can't fire him for
whistleblowing which is a smart legal
angle okay so this is an amazing
follow-up story this amazing follow-on
story okay ready for this I love this so
much so the entire claim by Google was
how dare you say that women are unsuited
for tech he never said that how dare you
say that women on average are more
emotional that's terrible you can't say
that women on average are more emotional
direct quote from NPR today quote a
senior software engineer reportedly has
been fired by Google after a memo he
wrote criticizing diversity initiatives
is leaked and sparked protests on social
media another software and
who used to work for Google Kelly Ellis
says some women who still work at the
company stayed home on Monday because
the memo made them quote uncomfortable
going back to work so your entire case
is that women are no different from men
in their emotional state and women are
no different from men on average and yet
when a memo comes out about the
differences between women and men women
stay home for emotional reasons this
entire story was created to make
conservatives look good I mean it's
truly incredible like if you want to
prove him right on every score that
women are different from men on average
that that Google has a leftist bias and
they kill everyone who gets in their way
all you have to do is is this the story
makes it clear that all of this is true
it's just amazing stuff okay before I go
any further and I want to talk about how
this sort of mentality is now infusing
all society and dividing us from one
another I first want to say thank you to
our sponsors over the u.s. ECA so after
two years just the other day an army vet
was finally acquitted of homicide
charges after a jury found his use of
deadly force to be justified under
Colorado's castle doctrine the Castle
Doctrine is the law because someone
invades your house then you can defend
your property in your in your life now
let me tell you the story because once
you hear the story you'll be surprised
in several months of trial Sergeant
Michael Galvan is a 12 year army vet and
he's shot an intruder in 2015 after the
intruder lunged at him so why did it go
to trial because left wingers say that
sergeant Galvan didn't have the right to
defend himself because the intruder was
in his garage not his home so the Castle
Doctrine didn't apply he's just in his
garage
okay can you believe that now we already
know that we cannot rely on the screwed
up legal system to ever get it right in
this case it cost sergeant Galvan a lot
of time money to prove his innocence
just for following the law that's why
you need the u.s. CCA the u.s. CCA
believes everyone has the right to
protect themselves no matter where they
are which is why they want to give you a
chance when a brand-new gun when you
activate your u.s. ECA membership before
midnight tonight visit defend my family
now calm defend my family now.com cancer
that's defended my family now calm they
helped you in case you have to shoot
somebody or shoot at somebody they help
you through the legal process they
ensure that you're not going to lose
your livelihood and lose your lose your
life in court that's what defend my
family now comments more plus you have
that chance to win a brand-new gun when
you activate that us CCA membership
again defend my family now calm you owe
to yourself and your family
to go over to you Seca and check it out
defend my family now calm okay so this
is not the only story about corporate
attempts to to crack down on the right
unfortunately this is becoming more and
more common we saw just a couple of days
ago we talked about the story with Lena
Dunham trying to out a couple of
American Airlines employees who are
supposedly talking about how the push
for transgender children is really
despicable the push to to push children
into transgenderism is gross and they
wouldn't and they wouldn't involve
themselves in it and Lena Dunham tweeted
out in American Airlines tried to crack
down on the employees and they found out
that Lena Dunham is a pathological liar
because that's what she is and it's just
another demonstration that for the left
free speech only applies to them it
doesn't apply to anyone else again
Google has the right to fire anyone
American Airlines has the right to fire
anyone who wants but if we can't live in
a society where we acknowledge the
differences of view generally do not
mean that you should be fired then you
know this is then it's going to be very
hard to live in the society now I will
say there's an exception okay if
somebody who's West Wing comes to work
at Daily wire and then they start
promulgating left-wing views I think
that that's perfectly within bounds for
me to say you don't represent our
company you got to go but Google is not
about right left
Google's entire companies based around
the idea of information being shared
among lots of people well just because
they don't like the information that's
being shared that doesn't mean that you
can just dump people especially because
we're not even talking about in this
case a guy actually writing a memo
saying women shouldn't be working at
Google right I mean there you could at
least say it is creates a hostile work
environment there's nothing in the memo
that creates a hostile work environment
they just went over their skis and
suggested that that's what was happening
so that they could fire the guy but
there is this tendency now to infuse
every aspect of American life with
politics so another aspect of this
there's new push for colin kaepernick in
the NFL so as we talked about Colin
Kaepernick was a very crappy quarterback
the last couple of years he was the
worst rated quarterback in the NFL last
year and he was demoted so that he was
playing behind some other garbage
quarterback for the San Francisco 49ers
and finally he was let go and the
popular media Howe line has been that
the Colin Kaepernick was let go because
he note from the national anthem not
because he's a crappy garbage
quarterback so now the the Dolphins the
Miami Dolphins from their quarterback
guy named Ryan
tannin bowel medley
he's injured and they had to pick up
another quarterback so they picked up
Jay Cutler okay Jay Cutler I'm a Chicago
Bears man Jay Cutler is the most the
most disappointing quarterback in
Chicago Bears history he came in with
his stellar reputation for having a gun
of an arm which he does but he was not a
good decision maker in the pocket and so
he threw lots of interceptions that said
he was sort of a middling quarterback in
terms of qbr in terms of quarterback
rating he was not like on the very low
end of the spectrum he was not the best
quarterback in the league but he
certainly was not Colin Kaepernick
quality bad the Dolphins picked him up
and naturally the media are now
suggesting that the NFL must force some
team to take Colin Kaepernick here is
Shannon Sharpe over at Fox Sports 1
making this case Ken is this a good move
or bad move by the Dolphins it's a bad
move yes and it's it's embarrassing
quite frankly and and I get the Dolphy
they were in the bye Tannehill goes down
with the Bini injury the severity it
seems to be as more news trickles out
there's a great chance that he's
probably going to be done for the entire
season
so I get it so I've just tried to figure
the Jay Cutler called all 32 teams and
saying if somebody goes down I'm willing
to come out of retirement probably not
I wonder if Jay Cutler called the Miami
Dolphins and says I want to play and
then there's this narrative about cap
says okay well he wants too much money
it's amazing how the Miami Dolphins
pound 10 million dollars for a guy a
retired guy not a guy that last threw a
pass in January our retired guy you know
not we don't want you but here's what's
the most egregious part of it skip they
love Colin Kaepernick a guy that last
threw a pass in January of 2017 ok so a
couple of things number one it's Ryan
Tannehill not Ryan Tannenbaum he's not a
member of the royal Tenenbaum family but
but is what he says you know why are
they going after Jay Cutler okay Jay
Cutler retired may 5th 2017
he retired five minutes ago so this idea
that he's been retired for five years
and they dragged him out of retirement
if they went and hired Brett Favre maybe
there's a case there but this idea that
it must be discrimination against
Kaepernick that's preventing him from
getting a job maybe what's preventing
him
getting a job is two things he creates a
backlash among the fanbase and two he's
a really crappy quarterback but sharp is
not the only person who's saying that
politics ought to infuse the gridiron
Stephen H Smith is saying the same thing
saying the NFL should actually cram down
on team they should find some team to
cram down Kaepernick on that there's
going to be an uproar and uprising to
some degree and I think that the NFL is
going to feel compelled to make sure
that this man has a job yes you have the
naysayers and the detractors and you
certainly understand that there are no
african-american owners in the sport of
the National Football League that the
vast majority of them or what are white
as opposed to Shere Khan who was in
Jacksonville and he's Pakistan is like I
think I'm remembering an MP in Pakistan
a Pakistani rather so when you take that
into consideration
it looks daunting but nevertheless I do
believe there's a whole bunch of people
out there who are in support of Colin
Kaepernick as this continues to
transpire with scrubs of being picked
before him you're going to see an uproar
and potentially an uprising that's not
something that the NFL is going to want
that's not going to be good for business
and I think ultimately somebody's going
to capitulate
okay so again it's bad for business for
the NFL demand they did the same thing I
remember with Michael Sam who is a
seventh round draft pick by the NFL
apparently the heads of the NFL called
up all of the various NFL teams and they
said you need to pick Michael Sam we
need to get him on the on the fields we
need to have them signed by a team
because he was openly gay and came out
right before the draft and was on the
cover of Sports Illustrated and so it's
impossible that the NFL wouldn't engage
in this again it's hilarious to watch
the left spin itself in circles over
dictating to private businesses what
they can and must do okay so according
to the left it is a must to force a
religious Baker to cater a gay wedding
must happen okay the government must
force that also the same people will say
that Google must fire somebody who
disagrees with them to understand
religious people must cater to people
with whom they disagree but Google must
fire people with whom they disagree if
this all seems a little weird if this
all seems like it's just outcome driven
that's because it is from the left all
it is about promulgating leftist values
it's not really about free speech or
about the ability to express yourself in
any way again
do I think that colin kaepernick should
be hired regardless of his stance on the
national anthem i actually sort of do
but i will say that there is a that his
business is actually two things okay
unlike google where the guy who works at
google his job is to code that's his
entire job
there's no backlash you know that really
matters outside the workplace with
regard to his personal views on on
females you know what colin kaepernick
has two jobs one is to throw a pass well
which he can't do and the second is to
actually draw a crowd which he has
succeeded in alienating okay so before I
go any further I want to get to Trump
material next and what's going on with
the Trump administration I think there's
a lesson that Donald Trump should be
learning from this week that's a really
good lesson before we get to any of that
first I want to say thank you to our
brand-new sponsors over at Dollar Shave
Club Dollar Shave Club is the best
choice it's the smarter choice a great
shave and a great price conveniently
delivered right to your door you're
never going to worry about going out to
the store again and buying razors at a
really overpriced at a really overpriced
sticker
you know it's an awesome light pack it
is a no-brainer instead of buying a
cheap disposable razor or spending a
fortune on really expensive razors
instead you use your DFC executive razor
with there dr. Carver's shave butter and
a blade just glides gently and it gives
you a really smooth shed so orthodox use
we can shave above the jaw line with the
syringe but I use it underneath my chin
every single day and it is just glorious
it is the best razor that I've ever used
and you can get it when you go to Dollar
Shave Club also they send you these new
razors every month so that means that
you are going to never be shaving with
the dull blade which is what how many
times have you had the dull blade you
forgot to go to the store and pick up
the razors and now you're stuck taking
basically a butter knife and shaving
yourself with it so there's no need for
that
the Dollar Shave Club right now for a
limited time new members get their first
month of the executive razor with a tube
of their dr. Carver's shea butter for
just five dollars with free shipping
after that rates is just a few bucks a
month there's a $15 value for only five
dollars in your first month box you get
an awesome a weighty handle the focus
set of four cartridges and a tube of
their shave butter after that first
month replacement cartridges ship
automatically at the regular price no
hidden fees no commitments you can
cancel anytime you want by the way they
also have other great products they have
shampoo they have body wash all of which
smells terrific and really does the job
join the club today right now at Dollar
Shave Club calm
roschmann that is dollarshaveclub.com
slash been again use that flash pens
that they know that we sent you also you
can get that special deal where you're
getting the the razor and the dr. carver
shea butter for five bucks with Free
Shipping and after that just a few bucks
a month for the razor refills again
dollarshaveclub.com slash been
dollarshaveclub.com slash men okay so i
want to move on to talk a little bit
about first of all final note on all of
this attempt by the left to infuse all
of our businesses with politics the more
they do this the more society is going
to become polarized right now we like
even last year we all watch the NFL
together it's something we could talk
about the watercooler
it is important that in america we have
things that are water cooler talk it is
very important that we in the united
states have stuff that we can talk about
with each other even if we disagree
about politics and if we don't do that
it actually destroys the public
discourse that's what happened with the
NFL with colin kaepernick
people couldn't talk with each other
about the NFL without devolve into a
conversation about police brutality and
race for no apparent reason right and it
was very polarized along racial lines
now you're seeing the same with google
you're going to see conservatives who
say okay i'm no longer going to use
google chrome instead i'm going to be
downloading safari and i'm going to use
or or some other browser and i'm going
to use that we're going to be using
different sources of information because
google is felt to have a bias which they
clearly do there's going to be companies
that are started to fight that bias this
already exists on the right with a bunch
of other web companies i mean this is
why this is why the entire conservative
what media exists why daily wire exists
if the left didn't suck so much their
media job then we here at the daily wire
wouldn't exist right we have to exist
accounts or balance the force of the
left-wing media that's a good thing it
would be a better thing if everybody
were just honest in their reporting
instead of lying about everything okay
so in just a second i want to get to
everything trump related and a big
lesson for president Trump that is
coming from this week that I think is a
really good lesson for President Trump
if he's willing to take it but but for
that are going to have to go over to
Daily wire calm so first of all if you
listen up in in just a few minutes I
guess about half an hour now 45 minutes
you should stick around for Andrew
Klavan show if you subscribe to daily
wire.com at $9.99 a month you can watch
that entire thing live you can watch our
show live it's not just an audio show it
is a video show and you can watch it at
daily wire.com
Andrew Clavin show starts live at 10:15
Pacific time michael Knowles's show
starts live
and I think 12:30 today Pacific time so
we have a lot of content for you over at
Daily wire you can part of the mailbag
you can be part of the mailbag and get
your life's questions answered without
being part of the daily water team so
$9.99 a month gets you that plus the
website for free make sure by the way
you check out both moles podcast and
kleavon's podcast regardless even if you
don't get the subscription or 499
dollars you can get this this greatest
of tumblers where you get the annual
subscription all of the things I just
mentioned plus the leftist tears hot or
cold daily white or tumblr glory be I
mean it is just fantastic in fact I just
got this letter I want to read you about
this legendary tumblr because it's
hilarious and it just came in literally
32 minutes ago quote the stories I have
heard about this fine piece of art
forged in Valhalla by the hammer of Thor
the ones humbler to rule them all are
enough to desire to have one of my own
I'll place it over my fireplace praise
it show my children and grandchildren is
a symbol a symbol of everlasting fight
between good and evil and eventually
when my eyes closed for the last time
I'll have my ashes poured into this
greatest of all containers to be one
with it for all eternity okay I just
have to thank me Hall for that wonderful
description of the tumbler I couldn't
have said it better myself you got that
for just $99 that's amazing right I mean
for $99 you get everything plus this
tumbler in which you can one day put
your ashes so it's pretty incredible
check that out over a daily wired I can
already want to listen later go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud we are currently as
I say the number one news and politics
podcast in the United States we are
number two overall in the United States
on iTunes so make sure that you leave us
a review and subscribe if you do it fast
we can overtake Oprah people let's do
this thing to make it happen go check it
out daily wire comm or checks out later
in iTunes or SoundCloud we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
all righty so here is I keep saying
there's there's a lesson for president
Trump here's a lesson for President
Trump to tap in from this week he's on
vacation this week and guess what things
are going really well like a lot of the
news that's coming out from the Trump
administration is really good you know
why because Trump isn't tweeting stupid
crap because he's not firing and hiring
he's not grabbing people like Anthony
Sierra Moochie
from his American psycho psycho coke den
and bringing him in and using him as his
as his communications guy we're not
getting the the chaos every time Trump
opens his mouth
Trump is quiet and guess what then you
see stories like this appearing in the
press because guess what the media
actually has to fill the time okay
here's the dirty little secret about
media we need content if Trump isn't
providing content we will get content
from somewhere else the content this
week for Trump has been quite good
yesterday or the day before Monday
there's a 15 to 0 UN resolution that was
passed to create new sanctions on North
Korea including China and Russia voting
for it that's a major accomplishment by
the Trump administration today The Daily
Mail is reporting and so is the
Washington Post quote the war against
Isis has taken dramatic strides since
Donald Trump became president with the
US and its allies we're claiming swaths
of Iraq and Syria in fact of all the
land reclaimed by the us-led coalition
since 2014 nearly one-third has been
taken since Trump took office that's
thanks to Trump's decisions who delegate
decisions and engage in a campaign of
annihilation brett mcgurk the State
Department senior envoy to the anti
Islamic state coalition told The
Washington Post since its peak in early
Isis has lost 78 percent of its occupied
territories in Iraq and 58 percent in
Syria in total that is 27,000 square
miles of territory 8,000 of which has
been taken since February of this year
so what should this teach President
Trump it should teach him a few things
one when you delegate to good people and
leave them alone and don't mess around
with the good things happen and this has
been true at the EPA when we're cutting
regulations this has been true with
regard to hiring and firing or that
where Trump has cut 11,000 jobs delegate
to the right people and shut up okay
he's on vacation right now he's
disappeared the media doesn't have
anything to feed off of this is why this
great why' that Trump's tweets make his
presidency stronger no Trump's tweets
make his presidency eminently weaker if
you were just and go quiet and to starve
the media of material then all that
would happen is that the media would be
forced to actually cover the news they'd
actually be forced to cover the news and
they book more and more desperate right
because the left is desperate at this
point listen how desperate they sound
okay MSNBC I had on a guest named Dean
Obadiah he's actually usually at CNN and
he's a Muslim comic which is in his case
oxymoronic he is he's not a funny man
but he says that the Trump it's just
like a swastika it's a trump swastika
the word trump is like a swastika
I spoke to the executive director of
this mosque earlier today and he was
saying that the the relations that they
enjoy with the community are generally
stronger you know Muslims have been in
America for a long time there's a in in
in in some of these areas there's
slightly newer communities some of them
are first-generation and and he feels
that the community is not hostile toward
them and that's a great thing and you
saw that I saw immediately that within
hours of the attack the leaders of
different faith communities standing up
and saying we're with you this mosque
according to local media reports they
did get some emails and hate mail before
just a week ago another Muslim cemetery
in the Minneapolis suburbs was
vandalized with swastikas graffiti since
January had five mosque burned down in
America by arson that's according to the
police we've had swastikas written on
mosque we've had the word Trump painted
on masa New Jersey Iowa New York for
some the word Trump is becoming a
modern-day swastika for some they like
it why why is that becoming a modern-day
swastika first of all we don't have any
evidence who did that I mean maybe his
suggestion here seems to be that that
there are people who are alt writers who
use Trump as their standing but like the
that's that's such an exaggeration Trump
is in modern-day swastika
masking water is the most corrupt person
in Congress you say we're going to
impeach Trump by December hey let her go
so I believe it is possible to impeach
him how long is it going to take I don't
know but I give it to about December the
entire thing okay I give it to December
okay so that's not going to happen but
the left is so crazy that this is what
they're promulgating and you know what
makes them count
when nothing's happening it makes them
sound totally over the moon when nothing
is happening it makes them sound bat
poop okay when they when they're going
crazy and Trump is just quiet it makes
them sound like wound bags because they
are loon bags and here's the other thing
all the divisions on the right regarding
Trump they go away when Trump does good
things and when the left is crazy okay
these are the things that unify the
right if you want a unified right what
you want is Trump to do positive things
and you want the left to continue acting
the way that they're acting at places
like Google shutting down to bait making
people on the right making moderates
feel threatened right that helps the
right that unifies the right then you
don't have to do the whole Trump as
litmus test Laura Ingraham was hosting
for Tucker Carlson last night and listen
to her dividing conservatives amongst
themselves on the issue of Trump do you
know what a liberals idea of Armageddon
is no it's not a nuclear North Korea but
a successful trump presidency do you
know what the never Trump Republicans on
Capitol Hill fear the most now it's not
Isis and it's not a 5,000 point drop in
the Dow but a successful trump president
okay so that last statement is the one
that's really dumb okay this idea that
never Trump Republicans are looking for
Trump to fail that's what they fear is
Trump success know what they fear is
losing their seats and if you're losing
their seats
if Trump continues to do silly things so
again mr. president take a note from
this week you're having a really good
week okay this week has been great for
you thus far I understand it's only
Tuesday but it's been a great week okay
that's better than it's been in the past
couple of weeks okay so you ended last
week on a relatively high note now the
first couple of days have gone great
why because you were quiet just be quiet
okay and everyone will unify around the
good policies your administration pushes
and around the idiocy of the left you
can create another victorious coalition
around those two things you're going to
break the coalition if you decide that
you have to meddle create chaos
Jabar be the center of attention all
those things need to stop if you stop
that every day can be like today every
day can be me just doing good Trump all
day that's what I would like to do
I would like to that about any president
okay forget whether it's Obama or Trump
I would say all the things that I want
them to do right now the Trump
administration is doing things this week
that I want them to do and it is not
being degraded by you
tweeting about how Attorney General Jeff
Sessions is a jerk right so why don't we
just stick with that lesson that's it
that's a positive lesson okay time for
some things I like things I hate and
then we'll deconstruct a culture a
little bit so things I like we're doing
sort of Cold War classics in honor of
Venezuela now I guess an honor of Google
since the the gulags Iraq but the book
is witnessed by Whittaker Chambers this
is sort of the classic of Cold War
espionage thrillers it's not fiction
right it is a nonfiction book about this
guy named Whittaker Chambers who
testified against the Alger Hiss held
rehearse was a top State Department
official in the in the FDR and Truman
administration and turned out that he
was actually a Soviet spy and Whittaker
Chambers knew about it and was slandered
by the press and called a liar and he
was threatened his life was threatened
by the Communist Party and it's all
about what the Communist Party actually
was doing in the United States and how
the left
essentially lent them cover the book is
witnessed it's a loan book about 500
pages but it is a very quick read it is
very well-written Whittaker Chambers is
a terrific writer witness you can check
that out over at amazon.com okay other
things that I like so I have to say that
I love this so much the Royal Dutch
Airlines I under as I said before I
don't see the need for corporations to
politicize themselves but they also you
seem to feel the need to make everything
political now what's your innate to me
because I just want to fly my airline I
don't want to hear about gay propaganda
or transgender propaganda I just want to
apply my airline so this is what Royal
Dutch Airlines tweeted out yesterday
okay for those who can't see it is a
picture of three separate sets of belt
buckles one is two bachelor buckles one
is two insertion in inserts into the
buckle and one is the insert and the
buckle right and there on all of the
belts themselves are painted rainbow
colors and then it says it doesn't
matter who you click with happy hashtag
pride Amsterdam and then gay pride flag
there is a problem with this particular
tweet that I love very very much okay if
you were to be an air turbulence two of
these three buckles do not work okay if
you're sitting there trying to insert
the buckle into the buckle you will die
while the plane becomes turbulent at
30,000 feet if you are trying to insert
the insert into the insert then
everything will will go dark for you as
your head smashes into the overhead
compartment
during turbulence only one of these
three things so thank you for making the
thank you for making a biological case
in favor of heterosexuality Royal Dutch
Airlines in your inane and stupid
attempts to demonstrate to the world
just how just how tolerant and diverse
you are pretty incredible stuff speaking
of ridiculously gay propaganda that goes
wrong this gay clothing company is now
trying to no joke trying to restore the
swastika to its original symbolism as an
element of peace good luck with that
gang so we can play the video now and
play it so this is a swastika and it's
picture ruffians 5,000 years old it's a
symbol of peace it's a symbol of love of
infinity of life but one day Nazism they
took the swastika rotated it by 45
degrees and turn it into hatred and
turned it into power they stigmatize the
swastika forever they won they limited
our freedom or maybe not the swastika is
coming back together with beef together
with love together with respect together
with freedom
introducing the new swastika and then it
got rotated 45 degrees looking just like
Hitler's swastika they didn't even have
the brain to make the swastika back to
its original angle right they just left
it 45 degrees in half of their gear and
then it says piece with swastika love
with swastika Zen with swastika
yes ah I love it so much so I hope that
I only hope that one day when the gage
swastika flies above companies that have
fired all of the religious people then
we can understand that peace love and
Zen were all with the swastika the
happiest person in the world today is
John Nolte who's been talking about the
gage swastika for years with regard to
that companies destroying religious
people's lives who don't decide to
participate in same-sex weddings I love
it ka designs claims their intention
behind using the symbol commonly
associated with the Nazi Party was to
reclaim the symbol to represent the
LGBTQ community go for a gang just enjoy
ourselves love it love it
and of course everybody is like wait
what what are you doing now
it's a huh hey what so I assumed that
their next campaign will be to reclaim
crematoriums because it turns out that
Crematory has been used for thousands of
years for actual cremations like people
who want to be cremated so I guess we
can just reclaim Crimmins sometimes a
symbol is so poisoned that you might
just want to let it go the same people I
assume who are in favor of the swastika
I'd like to see them try to reclaim the
Confederate flag next since apparently
we've decided the Confederate flag is
the root of all evil in the United
States a spectacular job everybody who's
up with the gay propaganda this which is
well done robes airlines ka designs
you've done yeoman's work yeah well done
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate okay so Stephen Colbert last night
spends his time going after eric bolling
eric bolling has been suspended from his
show the specialist on Fox News after
allegations of sexual harassment against
guests and here's Stephen Colbert
playing high and mighty with with Eric
Bolling the huffing poe is reporting
that a co-host of the specialists and
guy whose cologne you can smell through
the TV eric bolling
that coworkers an unsolicited photo of
male genitalia via text message oh my
god whatever happened to old-fashioned
courtship what a gentleman would
Telegraph his genitalia here is my penis
stop he did it stop sending me your
penis stop seriously stop stop
bowling has been suspended while Fox
News investigates but he denies the
charges sort of according to his lawyer
mr. bowling recalls no such
inappropriate communication he doesn't
recall how do you forget sending someone
your bits and pieces okay so obviously
Colbert and the rest of the left media
oh my god look at Eric Bolling and so
check okay so I would just like to
remind people and it is by the way if
he's texting his genitals unsolicited to
people that is sexual harassment it's
disgusting
okay now with that said Stephen Colbert
took over for does anyone remember David
Letterman yes David Letterman okay David
Letterman told the audience openly on
his show that he had sexual
relationships with female staffers on
his on his staff adding that he forked
over a bogus two million dollar check as
part of an extortion plot on the matter
okay so what happened he did it for
years and yet no one seemed to mind
Hollywood playing hypocrite when it
comes to this kind of stuff again I'm
fine with ripping people up and down for
sexual harassment I have no problem with
that but I just find a little ironic
that people in Hollywood are willing to
forgo ripping their leftist colleagues
engaged in sexual harassment like a
little consistency would be good okay I
am not in favor of sexual harassment if
somebody on the right does it like if
Eric Bolling did it he should not have a
job okay and if somebody in love does it
they should not have a job either but
I'm consistent in this this is a
Letterman's audience and so there's a
little bit of irony to this whole shtick
okay now let's do a little bit of
deconstructing the culture so
deconstructing the culture today ABC
News and The Associated Press are
pushing very very hard this new idea
that young tiny children should be able
to determine their own gender oh yes ABC
News has a piece today it says in some
ways rainbow day camp is very ordinary
kids arrive with a packed lunch make
friendship bracelets play basketball
sing songs and get silly whenever
there's a story that starts this way you
know that it's going to go off the deep
end
very shortly right whenever they it
started off like any normal day until
Bob murdered his wife and fed her to the
dog right all these stories it seemed
like a relatively normal place until it
turned out to be one of London's
graveyards but it always starts out with
it starts on they packed lunch make
friendship bracelets but it is unique
from the moment campers arrive each
morning I check in each day campers make
a nametag with their pronoun of choice
some up for she or he or a combination
of she he or they or no prowl none at
all some change their pronouns daily to
see what feels right the camp in the San
Francisco Bay Area mm-hmm
caters to transgender and gender fluid
children ages four to twelve okay
so once you get to twelve I think that
we can start having conversations about
you know whether you are experiencing
gender dysphoria at the age of four if
you are a parent sending your
four-year-old to a camp that is
reinforcing gender identity disorder or
gender dysphoria whichever term you
choose to use you are doing something
deeply wrong I have a three and a half
year old it is insane - insane to
suggest that a four year old is capable
of deciding his or her sex that's
utterly crazy and parents who are doing
this are doing something deeply sinful
something deeply nasty to their own
child it is your job to guide your child
this idea that your child is supposed to
lead you into something like sexual
identity when they have no clue what
sexes have no idea what their genitals
are for don't have hormones okay this is
just ridiculous it's just ridiculous is
it the enrollment has tripled to about
60 young campers this is demonstrable
fact by the way this is true across the
board it's true in Australia it's true
Great Britain every place where the
transgender movement has started to push
what they've seen is an enormous number
the number of kids who are now looking
to transition has skyrocketed
dramatically now if the West would say
is all these people were just waiting to
transition and now in societies become
more accepting and you're seeing more of
this behavior okay or it is possible
that gender confusion can be created by
environment or exacerbated by
environment this notion the environment
has nothing to do with sexual identity
or sexual orientation or sexual behavior
is just asinine it's not true
okay there's been no evidence of this
whatsoever according to the left sexual
orientation sexual behavior gender all
of those things are hardwired but sex
itself is not hardwired sex itself is
completely malleable this is a
scientific potentially anti-scientific
and to pretend that small children
four-year-olds should be going to camps
where they are encouraged to rebel and
gender confusion is is purely disgusting
it's currently discussing particularly
since statistically speaking 80% of
small
children who suffer from even gender
identity disorder right actually suffer
from it grow out of it by the time they
hit puberty
so just what what a terrible society
we're creating or when we suggest the
children ought to be making decisions
about their own sex lives but it don't
ought to be abdicating on that score
really really terrible and the the the
article contains have a six year old
Gracie Maxwell is dancing in the
sunshine Adam as a Miley Cyrus song
blaster from outdoor speakers the
freckle blue-eyed blonde wore her hair
on in a braid on one side Gracie's a boy
by the way when she could talk I don't
remember a time when she didn't say I'm
a girl it said her mother Molly Maxwell
who still trips over pronouns but tries
to stick to she then it grew in
intensity I'm a sister I'm a daughter
I'm a princess we would argue with her
she was confused we were confused living
in liberal-minded bay area made it
easier the Maxwells found a transgender
playgroup saut specialist in a
four-year-old let Gracie grow her hair
dressed as a girl and eventually changed
her name what what a joyous occasion I
mean look at look at this kid here on
the right with little kids do you think
maybe six five the one on the right with
the multicolored hair here that's a
decision by the parents to allow this
kind of this kind of stuff it's a
decision by the parents to revel in this
kind of stuff and make themselves feel
better as parents as this kind of stuff
listen I wouldn't want to be a parent
who has a kid who has to deal with
gender dysphoria or gender identity
disorder but for me to abdicate the
decision to the four-year-old is just
it's not an adult okay to anti adult and
it's anti civilization okay so uh this
unfortunately is going to continue
because the left is fully ensconced in
its own navel-gazing with regards to the
new civil rights movement is created for
itself it's not a civil rights movement
at all it's a way of destroying
childhood innocence
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow to
talk about more fallout I'm sure from
Google and the latest in the news i'm
ben shapiro this is the venture hero
show
[Music]